[Music]
okay everybody i'm
really really really excited today
because
as i am snowed in i have the honor of
talking
to tamlin tomida aka
kumako from cobra kai and karatekid2
how you doing today tamlin very well
thank you steve thank you for having me
happy snow day um i was just showing him
off because i'm here in l.a so it's
totally sunday i'll switch it over to
you so you can get the view
oh there you go yeah i'm just so jealous
but uh i'm i'm so thrilled to be here
with you all
and and look forward to the conversation
we're going to have
yeah so i i have so many questions i've
just while i was watching cobra kai
season 3 i was like
this is so amazing to see tamlin back
now in this franchise
now for you when you saw cobra kai
came out season one on youtube what was
going through your head were you like i
cannot believe this is happening
is there a chance that kuniko's coming
back like what exactly i think it's a
pretty universal response right
everybody's you know
it because it's the anticipation it's
the excitement it's like
it's like the thrill is like oh my god
where are those guys going to be like 35
years later man
and they're exactly what you think they
could be
and and more so and i i i think the
brilliance of the three amigos josh heal
john hurwitz and hayden schlossberg plus
william zabka
and and ralph matio they they really are
careful as to how to bridge the stories
from the the karate kid franchise over
to cobra kai and they're just so
um fun that the show is so fun
it's just on this side of really good
cheese
it's nostalgic you know it's we're able
to laugh
at them and laugh at us because we are
so
you know uh entrenched in the 80s
and it's it's a fond and fun look back
and but with the forward vision as to
how we can look at the larusso
kids and uh johnny lawrence's kids and
all the kids out there in the cobra in
the cobra kai franchise
yeah that's what makes it so exciting is
because it it really does like center on
these kids but also
gives so much time and grace to the
characters like yours and kumako so it
kind of satisfies the new and the old
fan base
yeah yeah yeah i i think what it also
adds to my first question i asked you is
too is
where were you when you found out like
okay you're on board for cobra kai like
kumako's coming back like how did that
happen
um i i think i i i just was at home and
i think ralph texted or
called or emailed he he communicated to
me uh
in a very casual fashion goes hey would
you
and i go are you kidding sure um i just
need to look at the script
um and he said the the three amigos
would
love to uh send it to you again and i
i've said it in other interviews
forgive me steve for talking to other
people before you do oh no i'll i'll let
that
it's about it's about bringing the
authentic uh
and more a more authentic okinawan voice
to uh uh cobra kai yeah and
i mean speaking of that and we jump in
with kumako and she's in okinawa and
it's my favorite parts of season three
all the scenes with
kumako and i'm not just saying that
because thank you i
know i i feel it thank you yeah and i
think you i don't know what effect you
had on people but everyone was crying in
scenes with you you had all the tears
jerking moments you pulled it out of our
souls but
i i really wonder too to get to that
place of kumuko that he betrayed so well
was it daunting to jump into a character
from so
long ago you played as a child to now
like filling in the gap of like
what she was up to like was that crazy
but there's there again
to to thank you it's it was really
pulling in it was the hardest and the
easiest thing because
you all have to remember you fans of
karate kid that was the first thing i've
ever done
i have never acted before so when i
walked on set on karate kid
ralph and pat and nobu and danny and
yuji and all those guys
were my teachers i was working as i was
learning
and i was doing as i was learning i was
everything that i'm doing pat and
or ralph or john appleton our great
director and our
james crave our cinematographer clifford
coleman the first lady i remember these
names because they were so integral to
the birth of tamlin to meta actor
um so so i'm working in those scenes in
cobra kai the the episodes four and five
that you all saw
it it's it's levels of tamlin and ralph
working together it's like oh my god
we're
we're so old and it's like how your kids
and how's your parents
and but again it's again young tamlin
working with young ralph and ralph
really literally holding my hand said
you're gonna do good just
you know just have let's have fun
together and pat you know the memories
of
talking about pat and about reading the
letters from miyagi it's like
yes we're working on two parallel levels
at the same time and so again it was
easy
but it was also hard because those are
real things that
tamlin and ralph were probably feeling
in talking about pat merida while you're
seeing kumiko and danielson talking
about mr miyagi
yeah and that was clearly my favorite
scene of the whole season
and i wonder when you read the script
reading that scene did you get really
emotional like the first time your eyes
saw that
yeah of of course come on i mean we're
we're all human beings i mean if any one
of you guys
had read the script you would have gone
oh my god
together you know you have to keep
together because you know
timeline knows that kumiko has to give
this lesson
or give these treasures to daniel-san
or ralph you know and ralph is in in on
the reader
in the writers room so it's it's it it's
those those kinds of uh preciousness and
the rarity and the uniqueness
of you know ralph and pat being like
this
and right son and daniel being like this
so it was
it was that the double layeredness you
know the double stacked oreo
deliciousness that you can hell yeah and
you could definitely fill his spirit
in that area where you guys were it was
incredible and
yeah you know i think another thing
people were praising about your
performance with ralph was you guys had
such good chemistry like you did in
karate kid too but did that like click
right away on set like
did it feel like you never left or was
there like this weirdness like i haven't
like
you know so joyous it i i think i
squeezed him a bit to death
because i was just so i was like and i i
think you could tell i'm much more
noisier
than kumiko and much more demonstrative
um i'm just a valley girl from la so
it's like oh my god
and it's it was just trying to you know
uh burn on all the pistons you know and
and drive them all and just
put aside the joyousness of tamlin and
ralph aside and
have that you know those those you know
the ships that passed through the night
of kumiko and daniel's son so though
that's
that's what's sweet that's what was fun
for tamlin and ralph because it was like
oh these two you know in another life oh
well
but you know that's what that's enjoy
you know and and that's life
that's life you you still have that
tenderness that affection that
love and joy for another but you know it
just wasn't meant to be
you'll see okay that's gonna be a thing
where fans are gonna
debate this because fans that watch this
a lot of them want uh ralph to end up
with tamlin or
shall we say kumako with daniel's son
the fictional characters got it you're
fictional ralph machu and his lovely
wife phyllis are
oh my god i i i met philip on the set of
karate kid
wow this is the the the true love story
high school sweethearts and you know i
you just i felt it then and i still feel
it now
and it's just like oh wow everybody
should have that and luckily tamlin has
that but
it's just like just to see that uh and
sorry sorry to
to skew but yes i understand about the
the the fanship out there for
kumiko and and daniel but you know we'll
we'll see where
the the the universe takes us uh it
takes
takes the karate kid universe kobrakai
universe and
and i i love all the fans for loving on
that and for wishing that
yeah so so i think too i think the
reason people felt that way was
from my perspective watching the scenes
in okinawa
kumako financially and spiritually
saved daniel and she really was like an
mvp of this season
and i wonder though was that all
friendly or was there this like
true love that goes past the time they
had like
contributing to her motivations there i
think i think it's a little of
both i think that's a very very honest
answer because there there is no bl
there's no black or white
there's no you know it it's it's always
like
and it because we're human we we're
allowed to dream we're allowed to
fantasize we're allowed to
hope um of course and we keep those
hidden because
to act upon those will have consequences
it you know to to for for kumiko to
you know you know uh shut uh sashay in
you know into the the larusso's
household and encino i think they live
in encina right
which is like you know 10 miles down
down the road it's like
it would be really bold and it would
really upset that universe so
come on it's like but to you know dream
and
and that's why i understand and adore
fan fiction because
it allows people to really write and
create stories
and and to live out in their
imaginations as how they would want
things to turn out
and and that's a good and healthy
exercise
it's too it's the questions of carrying
out that i go
oh that's that's so sweet but we have
this this established world of karate
kid
and kobra kai and we want to honor those
characters we want to honor the
characters
uh in the collaborative minds of the
three amigos because they're the ones
who are
the gods and goddesses of what we're
seeing now on netflix
now if the three amigos give you a call
down the line and say we want you back
on the show are you going to do it
are you kidding of course i would love
it hey what do you what do you
it's like it it yeah it would it would
be
absolutely an opened we have an open
door
um i'm i'm able to write and text and go
oh my gosh that was a great scene
that's that's that's the that's the gift
for me to be able to have that door open
so
whatever they have in their minds
absolutely and and that goes for all the
characters that
i had worked with on karate kid yuji and
i are good friends
ralph and eugene ralph and yuji had a
blast a week before i arrived to atlanta
and set not two years ago
um and but you know the workout they had
into all the karate scene oh my god that
was a laugh
that just seemed just as observer it was
like oh my god
they're having so much fun as eugene
ralph you know the
the the the getting older bones
while as the the fury and the fierceness
of the young danielson meets
the young chosen still yeah 35 years
later was
so hilariously funny i i that's a gift i
wish that ever
that's the kind of behind-the-scenes
stuff that i wish uh
they had the the foresight and the funds
to see because that was yeah crazy just
the aching and you know oohing and
eyeing it at what they can do and what
they can't do and the price they paid
in in executing all those kicks and and
strikes
oh my gosh it was
i'm telling you stuff that i wish i i
wish i had uh film for you guys to
to to enjoy as well no but look it's
it's amazing to hear and you paint it
well visually and uh
yeah i think it's so cool that there's
such a die hard
fan base here for this franchise and how
it's been you know reformed and
i feel like a lot of you know you you
are a fan favorite and it's not just
because of kumako the character but
because of tamlin the person and actress
you're such a chill person a great
actress and
my my before i let you go i want to ask
you about tamlin how are you doing
during these crazy times
and what do you kind of do on your
day-to-day basis are you oh i'm watching
tv
or your reader oh wow i i try to try to
do all those things
and you know and i'm in the same boat as
everybody else i'm very fortunate to
have
a roof over my head and and and
wow steve you just touched a nerve
because it's again we're we're in such
uh tumultuous times but these are times
that deserve and demand
change to be able to provide comfort
and safety and security for all of us
and to have
you know first of all it's their health
so the rolling out of vaccines under
this new administration
is a blessing and it's a growing
blessing for the economy
to uh redefine itself as to
you know what's going on in the stock
market the ability for the gig economy
and for uh for all the companies that
are out there that actually serve
the people in terms of uh providing
you know services and things that we
need not just luxuries
you know not like a 24 karat gold toilet
that i need or anything like that
but it's it's just that so so regular
american
you know joes and jeans of every color
of every creed of every background
can say i'm an american i deserve a
place in the society and i'm going to
link
arms with my brothers and sisters and
say we can do this and let's get this
country going again
yeah tamlin that was just i'm inspired
now you for that
uh i think you're just lifting
everyone's spirits and you have that
aura about you
and you lifted mine today i'm snowed in
but i had so much fun talking to you
uh everyone obviously re-watch cobra kai
season three
you can even watch karate kid too i just
watched it on prime video it's
rent it for like three bucks keep
supporting the franchise it's so much
fun to watch
tamlin and is there anything else you
want to promote or plug before i let you
go
and you know what i i just i just wish
all the best for you guys who are being
snowed in because that's a serious thing
it's like a a sunny
a girl in sunny california doesn't think
these things about the inconvenience
about
you know yeah you know what do me a
favor
and and and and and make snowmen for me
because i've never had that
uh opportunity you know i've made wow
i've made snow angels
you know and it was like oh but i don't
think i had that
that that kind of buildable snow to make
those giant
life-size snowmen so so and
yeah and throw tomato at it for me
[Laughter]
okay i will i'll go out right now and do
it uh okay tamlin thank you so much
uh i hope to talk to you in the future
and i can't wait to see where your
career goes next
and i'm really grateful for you joining
me today thank you steve good luck and
have fun
thank you